allora la block gente centralizzata ma
scusi per questo lo sanno tutti è
scritto tutti i giornali cioè un
database organizzato in blocchi che sono
leggibili da tutti tutti possono
scrivere in un piccolo dei tag in
qualche pagina di questo qualche blocco
e non inalterabile a nessuno nessuno
portare il contenuto dei blocchi
nell'ordine dei blocchi e diciamo la
promesse credi che questa tecnologia
avrà per l'umanità chi più ne ha più ne
ha più ne dica perché sono praticamente
illimitate chi è che non apprezza
nell'altra abilità di un database chi
non apprezza la trasparenza chi non
apprezza la capacità di generare fiducia
a persone che appena si conoscono quindi
perché parlarne perché ci sono dei ma
ehi ma sono praticamente tre domande
fondamentali
questa a testa e croce questo registro
condiviso e c'era ma in realtà come si
fa a definirlo e avendolo definito come
si fa a implementarlo eppure alla fine
perché ci serve dunque cominciamo dalla
prima domanda dal co sa cos'è una block
chain decentralizzata
innanzitutto bisogna definire e capire
avete visto uno zoologo che classifica
gli animali in base a quante zampe
ciando certo ci sono i bipedi prive di
quadri di centimetri
no né dal colore che hanno e perché no
perché queste sono caratteristiche non
essenziali perché alla fine gli animali
a differenza dei minerali sono vivi e
forse classificarli in base a come si
riproducono e quindi danno la vita più
significativo che non il colore della
pelliccia benissimo e allora cos'è una
block chain decentralizzata spesso i
regolatori altri come si misura dal
numero di utenti più dentici iq center
centralizzato
beh io se fossi un imperatore con
milioni di sudditi
sono forse meno decentralizzato no
oppure dai del numero di nodi no e
perché no per lo stesso motivo di prima
questo non so
con caratteristiche essenziali allora
cos'è che è essenziale essenziale nella
blog chain e scegliere il prossimo
blocco perché nei blocchi che consistono
di tutte le transazioni che sono venute
se non stanno in block cento non sono
mai avvenute e se fossi io a scegliere
il prossimo blocco dico queste
transazioni verranno scritte nel mondo e
queste altre non mi piacciono le
vogliono scrivere avrei un potere più
assoluto di quello di luigi xiv
quindi forse il monarca assoluto per
eccellenza quindi cominciamo a
concentrare sul fatto che è la
partecipazione alla generazione dei
blocchi che rende decentralizzata un a
bruxelles
qualunque cosa avete visto e sentito da
ora in poi vi esorto a seguire questa
pista benissimo avendo già una dritta su
quella che era una bruciante
centralizzata e come si fa a farla
diciamo che non è facilissimo perché la
brook chain è un prodotto squisitamente
tecnologico e quindi senza tecnologia
non si va poi lascia una parte almeno in
block chain e perché è difficile perché
fino a pochi mesi fa vigeva il famoso
trilemma che diceva che se volete una
blog chain dovete scegliere al più due
di queste tre proprietà la
decentralizzazione e la sicurezza la
scalabilità
immaginiamoci che disastro se questo
fosse vero perché io sono blog chain by
design
voi siete un cliente cioè benvenuto a
bruxelles bel design
volete una boxe è incerto veneto una
proprio per voi in figura ci sono
veramente me servirebbe una sicura
allora ve ne do una non scalabilita nomi
come sempre giocato a parenti amici io
voglio una cosa scalabile e alla fin
fine chi sacrifichiamo bingo la
decentralizzazione e infatti
fortunatamente è stato così ma il
terrore in questo thriller ma è falso
la verità e punto che invece la
grandissima maggioranza delle tecnologie
block chaining non garantiscono la
decentralizzazione
qui ci sono varie tecnologie che voi
avete sentito parlare ne parleremo
brevemente puffo work della gara punto
state didn't recente nazione non se ne
parla non se ne vede neanche l'ombra
allora vediamo perché buffon
questa è una grande idea e la prima idea
tanto di cappello al signor la signora
nakamoto oi nakamoto non so quanti siano
il quale hanno inventato questo buffo
work che consiste questo guarda non sono
io a scegliere il posto blocco non sei
neanche tu
facciamo così generiamo un indovinello
matematico difficilissimo il primo che
lo risolve porta la soluzione ha il
diritto di attaccare il nuovo blog c'è
meno mano un sistema democratico
benissimo purtroppo estremamente lento
perché per essere sicuri che non ci sono
due soluzioni a pochi secondi l'uno
dall'altro
questo indovinello deve essere così
difficile e in quanti milioni di persone
ci provano a risolvere ce ne deve essere
uno ogni tanto altrimenti non sappiamo
nella blog c'è la genova di qua la
catena va al di là perché ci sarebbe una
forca e costoso perché a questo punto
non so se avete visto fate google miner
block cioè in maine e troverete un
immagine di migliaia e migliaia e
migliaia e migliaia di computer e super
specializzati che servono solo a
migliorare la probabilità che sia tu a
scegliere il prossimo blocco
il sistema è talmente costoso e cosa
succede quando le cose diventano troppo
costose che ce ne sono 123 che se lo
possono permettere
per esempio la catena bitcoin è forse la
più famosa catena è controllata da tre
mai input
ora ditemi voi se una catena controllata
da tre enti e centralizzata o
decentralizzato a me pare molto
centralizzata e se ciò non bastasse
l'inquinamento generato da tutti questi
computer è pazzesco che si consumano ha
riso o virginia mente consumano più
energia e liechtenstein poi delmas sul
tappeto da svizzera insomma le cose
crescono peggiore così va bene la
prossima tecnologia deleghe prof state
semplicissimo infatti voglio dire quasi
banale scegliamo vedete per le 22 21
personali non sono oneste figaro
sembrano e io credo anche che
continueranno a essere oneste per cui
diamo loro il mandato di scegliere il
posto di blocco per tutti noi
grazie a che vederci
allora diciamo questo è la buffa work
partiva da un'idea c'era questo
indovinello che possiamo risolvere tutti
e via via via alla fin fine è diventata
centralizzata ma questa era dei centrali
centralizzata e centralizzata e rimanga
centralizzata per sempre perché non è il
modo giusto di fare le cose non voglio
perdere tempo con altre altre proprietà
basti dire che tutti questi approcci
partivano da una logica fasulla e la
logica è questa
l'economia totale è sicura se la
maggioranza di un pezzettino di questa
economia e onesta se scusa non capito
bene e certo che non ha capito bene
perché non ha senso cioè immaginiamo
appunto qui c'è tutta l'economia
vedete quel pezzettino lì sono quelli
che se sono onesti tutto funzioni
altrimenti ci amiamo tutto in malora e
che sono questo pezzettino verde nella
puffo work sono questi tre minatori
nelle deleghe proposte che sono i 22
membri scelti chissà come buona fortuna
e e diciamo questo qui e non va bene
allora cosa c'è bisogno non bisogna
disperare una volta che abbiamo
inquadrato il problema io sono sempre
ottimista sull'ingegno umano e poi su in
generale sulla tecnologia e la
tecnologia dice che dobbiamo
semplicemente a cambiare è completamente
l'approccio voltiamo pagina
ed ecco invece questo è che io credo che
abbia le caratteristiche che vogliamo
che la puffo stake pura cosa vuol dire
vuol dire questo che ci sono come voi
sapete in coin ha per tutti sono questi
tokens famosi tokens ogni token ha lo
stesso potere di cappelli generare un
blocco e diciamo tutti questi token
queste monete però non stanno dove
stando stando nel portafogli ponte
essere spesi investite nelle varie
possibilità che ci dalla block chain e
se la maggioranza delle monete in tutto
il sistema è in mani oneste
il sistema è sicuro soffermiamoci sulla
terza cosa cosa vuol dire
vuol dire che non sono tre minatori che
decido se mi va io distruggono blog
chain deve essere la maggioranza di
quelle che posseggono alle monete nel
sistema
la maggioranza dell'economia devono
decidere di coalizzarsi coordinarlo con
l'altro e sparasse sul piede per
distruggere quella stessa economia di
cui posseggono la maggioranza forse ci
penseranno due volte prima di farlo che
dicevamo è la generazione dei blocchi
come avviene semplicissimo albi la
generazione dei blocchi ogni blocco
viene generato da un comitato
chi sono questi membri visto comitato si
scelgono a caso mille monete queste
monete scelte a caso appaltando a
qualcuno costoro sono i padroni i membri
del nuovo comitato e quel comitato e ci
sceglieranno un nuovo blocco e il
prossimo blocco un altro comitato si
scelgono altre mille monete a caso i
possessori formano un comitato che che
genera il genere blocco è una volta che
sono scelto che devo fare
se fossi scelto se una la mia monete
fosse scelta io faccio mandare in rete
un piccolo messaggio facile calcolare va
bene quindi che questa qui è come si
generano in blocchi però dico grazie
silvio di questa visione dall'alto della
pura fuffa state ma chi è che sceglie i
questi benedetti comitati certo non io
altrimenti sarebbe centralizzati sì ma
la cosa nessuno le scene si auto
scelgono dico come si auto scelgono
questa forse è la peggiore rea che abbia
mai sentito perché se io sono un
disonesto nemico statuto scegliere
certamente che mi scelgo per essere
membro di questo comitato a scegliere
questo blocco e anzi mi ha così pure per
il prossimo blocco e pensate che cosa
faccio per induzione mi scelgo due così
per cui sono sempre scegliere i blocchi
però non così semplice cosa vuol dire
auto a scegliersi vuol dire che aveva
una bella slot machine che tocca [ __ ] ok
questa famosa aveva uno mette i soldi ma
spingere l'aveva ho vinto ben questa
soft machine essendo crittografica non
posso pagare posso abbassare la leva una
sola volta e posso vincere o perdere se
vinco ottengo una prova un biglietto
vincente una prova dalla mia vittoria
la vincita e quindi cosa faccia un atto
in creta eco il mio biglietto vincente
essendo una prova tutti la possano
verificare ed ecco la mia opinione sul
blog super giova così fatemi dire perché
questo e decentralizzato perché
giustamente ogni volta c'è una lotteria
diversa a voi abbassate e vince si perde
ogni moneta fa una sua propria lotteria
come se avesse una manina che abbassa la
leva se voi possedete più morire forse
avete più possibilità di vincere gli
altri però è certamente sono mille
monete sparse in tutto il mondo
decentralizzato lo è chiudere
centralizzato di così fosse non si può
perché è scalabile
ma quanto tempo ci vuole rabba stare
questa leva un microsecondo una volta
abbassato lo ricordate
ma andiamo in onda il biglietto vincente
è la vostra opinione sul blog
quindi questo è facile da fare e adesso
diciamo perché supersicuro supponiamo
che io sia un personaggio tanto malevolo
quanto potente posso corrompere
istantaneamente mille persone in tutto
il mondo proprio allo schioccare della
mia vita
chi voglio corrompere i membri del
comitato però c'è un problema chi devo
corrompere perché voi state abbastanza
le vostre reti che i soldi voi chi ha
vinto che penso devo comprare the hotel
o quest'altra signora a shanghai
nessuna idea però una volta che gli auto
celti quindi la gara il biglietto
vincente lo dico recco mio biglietto
vincente ecco la mia opinione sul blocco
allora li conosco tutti e posso
corromperli istantaneamente e proprio
che ci ho fatto quello che dovevano dire
l'hanno già detto la loro biglietto
vincente nella loro opinione nel blocco
si sta propagando di realmente nel
network e non posso rimettono nella
bottiglia
né più né meno che il governo degli
stati uniti qualunque governo possa
mettere nella bottiglia un messaggio di
wikileaks che pure si propaga viralmente
quindi il sistema è sicuro perché
inizialmente non so chi corrompe e dopo
è troppo da bper per corromperli quindi
questo ci dà al di là della block ce ne
è uno strumento per potere davvero
progredire in modo democratico in tutto
il mondo mantenendo il mondo dei 100
realizzato
e diciamo come vedete questa trilemma
famoso facendo le cose un pochettino
poco ortodosse e si riesce a ottenere
quello che prima era considerato
impossibile di cosa impossibile nella
vita ce ne sono fortunatamente ce ne
sono molto poche perché spesso
impossibile e soltanto bene è
risolvibile ma perché la vogliamo questa
boxeur decentralizzata perché la
decentralizzazione è una fonte di
sicurezza enorme perché più partecipanti
ci sono al sistema più difficile
corrompere il sistema se tutto
centralizzato mette una bomba atomica su
un filo
basta non c'è più vicino è sparita
quando invece è talmente capillare che
tutti quanti che hanno una possibilità
del mondo possono essere capaci di
generare il blocco è difficile attaccare
il sistema
un altro motivo è che questo è un modo
di dare non soltanto la garantire la
sicurezza della rete perché ricordiamoci
che la block chain è un gioco che si
gioca di comunicazione e questo
protocollo di comunicazione si svolge su
una rete internet quindi non soltanto
uno può attaccare il protocollo ma anche
po all'antica tagliare fili e
riprogrammare le altre e tutti i sistemi
precedenti riprogrammando il re autres o
tagliando fili riuscivano a distruggere
la sicurezza quand'anche fossero tutti
onesti
quindi non è una buona cosa questa è una
sicurezza oltre ulteriore quella che
vogliamo
e poi come dicevo prima la
decentralizzazione vera garantisce
disintermediazione senza frodi e senza
costi e quindi garantisce tutti abbiamo
il desiderio di interoperare gli uni con
gli altri di interagire se lo potessimo
fare con sicurezza anche con le persone
che non conosciamo
mi sembra che sia un bel dono
all'umanità questo dono viene dalla
tecnologia io sono un tecnologo fiabesco
però mi pare che la tecnologia sia
profondamente umana da quando siamo
scesi dagli alberi abbiamo costruito il
primo strumento
viviamo meglio e siamo forse diventati
più mani di quanto avevamo prima non
toglie nulla al umma nese quanto di
umano è una è una giunta e diciamo anche
che specialmente il mondo si rende molto
più complicato molte tante delle nostre
aspirazioni non tutte ma la misura in
cui riusciamo a raggiungere dipenderà
dalla bontà delle tecnologia che siamo
riusciti a costruire una cosa però come
in tutto ci vuole tanto amore e tanta
forza di volontà e però noi abbiamo
qualcosa di meglio da fare di cercare di
raggiungere le nostre aspirazioni
io non credo per cui diciamo meritiamo c
la nostra tecnologia e godiamocela
quanto più possiamo
[Applauso]